there's an audience that's worried about
what's going to happen with YouTube okay
um but Rumble is winning because of what
YouTube is doing it's a badge of honor
right now for some people to say I got
kicked out of YouTube I don't think
that's a strategy but I don't think
that's a good strategy I don't know why
people are doing it YouTube give me six
tracks screw these guys I will never use
YouTube again brother go look at history
just 13 years ago or 12 years ago
competitor came to YouTube one of the
guys in the marketplace took a bunch of
YouTubers off they went all to the other
platform it lasted for a few years and
then it flopped and everybody came
begging back at YouTube so you got to be
pumping your breaks a little bit now
having said that I think I hope Rumble
makes it and I hope they kill it because
they're very necessary to keep YouTube
worse Yeah the more Rumble gets bigger
the better it is for YouTube creators My
Hope Is Rumble becomes a 20 40 100
billion Auto Company go light it up but
what I think gonna happen before they
become 100 billion Auto Company must go
buy Rumble uh uh either either he will
buy Rumble
um I think sax sits on the board of
Rumble now or something like that an
announcement was made this week so it's
a very interesting sex is the most
trusted guy to Musk feel is also
involved with Rumble feel sax musk all
go back to the PayPal mafia they could
come up and scoop up Rumble and say hey
can you fix all these things sacks
before we buy it yeah okay here's five
billion come to us we're going to put it
under uh Twitter and we're going to use
the technology the way we want to
because now sax is in there to give us
ideas then they're going to control
communication uh WeChat model that's in
Asia then they're going to pay Talent
more than anybody else is paying them
with the subscription model uh pay you
know pay my they're gonna do so many
different things who is the number one
customer service representative in
America today it's a guy named Elon Musk
is worth 200 billion dollars he reads
what people say
you can't get any Fortune 500 Co to come
out there and talk to its customers
they're locked up in the 80th floor all
the way to the top and they don't go
around talking to people this guy's like
okay let us look good good point we'll
work on that it's not a bad idea let us
look into it what do you mean by this
this is a this is a revolutionary type
of guy muscus he'll be the first
trillionaire in America I think it's
gonna take three to seven years
closer to seven but depending on what
happens to the economy Could Happen
three years I think in seven years that
guy's the first trillionaire do you
think it's a bad use of his time to be
responding to people in that way no not
how long should he do it for
you you have to know if you're as
curious as he is you know people who are
using your product know more about the
product than you do you only have one
lens okay you have to get other lenses
that you show your blind spots like even
right here right okay you know he's
doing what he's doing but that guy's
gonna say look at the camera this way
move that can you see that the logos or
we're not getting sponsored how about
this musk has that do you know what it
is it's it's very very unique it's like
Conor McGregor saying that he's gonna
fight again
who knows if he's gonna fight again but
the fact that his name is in the
conversation is good for the alcohol
brand he has it's good for the
entertainment brand he has good for the
management company because his brand is
wrapped around him as a fighter not him
as a retired fighter Elon answering five
tweets a day is just a reminder you know
I'm listening I'm here and this is my
company an attention Lottery that's it
that's it so not only tweet at me but
know when you're tweeting you're
tweeting on elon's platform you're
driving a Tesla that's elon's car and
all of us are literally invested in Elon
if some random person bought Tesla
I'd probably take my money out of Tesla
I I'm invested in Elon and Tesla is my
ability to invest in Elon the man if
there was a stock that was just Elon
stock
and it kind of wrapped up all his
different Ventures we would invest in
that I think that's pretty fast but I
don't think you're buying Facebook's
doctor buying Zuckerberg stock
whatever it ipo'd in 20 whatever that
was the line of thinking that I was
taught by my uncle he bought it and I
was like I'm hearing not good things
he's like I don't care I trust this this
kid knows what's going on I trust him
now he might be out of his depth
whatever but that was initially the
comparison I was making
thank you
[Music]